bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre cet après-midi sur notre
antenne l'examen de la proposition de
loi visant à réformer le règlement du
sénat
il s'agit pour la haute assemblée de
mettre en oeuvre la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008
le sénat a fait le choix du consensus il
a décidé de ne pas appliquer de temps
global des débats et de ne pas toucher
au sacro saint droit d'amendement des
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
l'instauration de ce temps global
on s'en souvient avait suscité une levée
de boucliers de la part des députés de
l'opposition
la réforme du règlement au sénat après
what également de renforcer le
pluralisme en garantissant la
représentation de tous les groupes
politiques au sens du bureau du sénat
mais également en commission le
président du sénat gérard larcher a
prévu une période d'un an pour tester ce
nouveau règlement à l' usage voilà pour
les enjeux du débat de cet après-midi
bonne science à tous l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion de la proposition
de résolution que j'ai eu l'honneur de
présenter tendant à modifier le
règlement du sénat pour mettre en oeuvre
la révision constitutionnelle conforter
le pluralisme sénatoriales et rénover
les méthodes de travail du sénat dans la
discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur patrice gélard
rapporteur de la commission des lois
vous avez la parole sur un porteur
on connaissait le texte de la chanson
il fallait le mettre en musique cela va
donc être fait aujourd'hui lors de
l'examen de la proposition de résolution
modifiant le règlement du sénat pour
mettre en oeuvre la révision
constitutionnelle conforter le
pluralisme sénatoriales et rénover les
méthodes de travail de notre assemblée
je tiens à souligner que ce projet de
résolution qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui est le résultat d'un long
travail qui a nécessité plusieurs noah
mois de réflexion au sein d'un groupe de
travail animé par le président larcher
avec deux co rapporteurs
le vice président bernard frimat et le
président de la commission des lois jean
jacques hyest
je crois qu'il convient de rendre
hommage à l'un comme à l'autre pour le
travail tout à fait remarquable qu'ils
ont accompli entre le mois d'octobre et
le mois de mars
le résolution à rechercher un certain
consensus mais ce consensus n'a pas pu
être véritablement atteint parce que il
a manqué au cours des discussions qui
ont pu avoir lieu
l'assentiment du groupe crc et des
membres du parti de gauche
il ya là une position tout à fait
logique qui fut défendu tant en
commission que lors du dépôt d'une
vingtaine d'amendements et qui sera
défendue tout à l'heure par le groupe
crc qui était tout à la fois opposait la
révision constitutionnelle opposés à la
loi organique et tout naturellement
opposait la modification du règlement
qui en est l'application
néanmoins notre commission sera amené à
émettre un avis défavorable aux
amendements déposés par le groupe crc
d'abord parce qu'ils la commission étant
d'un manque d'harmonie avec le groupe
crc sur cette question mais aussi
parce qu'un grand nombre de ces
amendements sont en contradiction soit
avec le texte de la constitution soit
avec le texte de la loi organique la
recherche d'un minimum d'accord a
conduit votre rapporteur à défendre le
point de vue selon lequel seuls les
amendements reconnu retenu par le groupe
du travail est défendu par les deux co
rapporteurs pourrait être maintenu et
concernant exclusivement l'application
de la loi organique et dès lors nous or
seront amenés à refuser tout homme
amendement qui aura pour but de remettre
en cause d'autres éléments de notre
règlement on pourra lors du rendez vous
fixé l'année prochaine
revoir éventuellement d'autres éléments
de notre règlement qui seraient devenus
obsolètes ou dysfonctionnelle mais ce
n'était pas le moment aujourd'hui que de
les aborder
c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
commission a donné un avis défavorable
aux amendements dont l'objet n'avait pas
de lien direct avec la révision
constitutionnelle et la loi organique
même si ces amendements étaient loin
d'être dépourvu de tout intérêt la
présente résolution respecte
naturellement la révision
constitutionnelle et la loi organique
met à pour notre assemblée un grand
nombre de conséquences
tout d'abord il convient de mentionner
que le nouveau règlement a pour but un
respect plus grand des droits des
parlementaires et des droits des groupes
parlementaires
ceci va apparaître dans le respect des
droits de l'opposition et des minorités
notamment ceux qui concernent la
composition du bureau du sénat prévu à
l'article 1er de la résolution le droit
pour les doutes les groupes minoritaires
une opposition a demandé chaque année la
création d'une commission denquête ou
d'une mission d'information prévue à
l'article 2 de l'ape du projet de
résolution la désignation au sein des
organismes extraparlementaires
conformément à l'article 5 à la
proportionnelle des groupes
le bureau des commissions permanentes
prévu à l'article 6 qui également met en
place la proportionnelle des groupes
mais on peut également mentionner la
place faite aux groupes lors des débats
thématiques prévues à l'article 20 dans
les débats sur les résolutions prévu à
l'article 25 ou les débats d'initiative
sénatoriales prévues à l'article 29 où
les questions cribles prévu à l'article
je n'entre pas dans le détail de ces
différentes institutions
je vous renvoie dans ces domaines à mon
rapport écrit le deuxième élément tout à
fait important c'est le renforcement
assez considérable du rôle de la
conférence des présidents notamment en
ce qui concerne les articles 14
car le 15 16 et 17 du projet de
résolution
nous serons amenés à accepter
au cours des débats qui vont suivre un
amendement déposé par notre collègue
hugues portelli pour tenir compte d'une
éventuelle opposition du conseil
constitutionnel au texte initial de la
résolution en effet et il était prévu à
l'article 16 que à l'article 17 parlons
que la fixation de l'ordre du jour
appartenait à la seule conférence des
présidents
nous n'avions pas mentionné le
gouvernement qui est maître tout de même
de deux semaines sorte sur quatre est
par conséquent nous risquions sur ce
point la censure du conseil
constitutionnel
pour éviter cette censure nous
proposerons d'adopter l'amendement
déposé par notre collègue portelli je
tiens également à mentionner le fait que
en ce qui concerne le renforcement du
rôle de la conférence des présidents
cela va apparaître dans une institution
de nouvelles créées dans la projet de
résolution c'est l'institution de la
clôture bien sûr la culture existait
déjà dans notre ancien règlement mais la
clôture est une nouveauté dans le
nouveau règlement lorsque
un débat risque de s'enliser il sera
possible de demander naturellement la
clôture comme auparavant mais à la
différence de ce qui se passe jusqu'à
maintenant
la conférence des présidents sera
immédiatement saisi et lorsque la
conférence des présidents sera saisie et
va tenter de trouver une solution pour
éviter l'enlisement
si elle n'y arrive pas la clôture
s'appliquera naturellement et en cas de
deuxième clôture à ce moment là il y
aura une limitation du temps de parole
des uns ou des autres qui interviendra
avec seulement le droit pour un
représentant par groupe d'intervenir
c'est un progrès et au moins cela nous
évite de recourir un temps de parole
limité comme l'attend globale comme
disait certain
il faudra voir à l'épreuve du temps ce
que deviendra cette motion de clôture
elle est peut-être le moyen d'éviter
l'enlisement de nos débats et la
prolongation trop longue de ceux ci le
troisième point qui apparaît dans ceux
de cette résolution c'est la recherche
de l'efficacité de la souplesse de
l'adaptabilité et de la transparence
alors cela va apparaître naturellement
dans l'organisation du travail des
commissions prévues à l'article 14 avec
également la présence du gouvernement
que nous avons été obligés de remettre à
l'intérieur du projet de résolution en
raison de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui exige la présence du
gouvernement même pendant les votes
cela pose naturellement un certain
nombre de problèmes et c'est ici que je
voudrais soulever sans doute la
nécessité d'adopter en complément de
notre règlement des règlements des
commissions pour préciser dans quelles
conditions
le ministe pourra ou pas se faire
assister par ses collaborateurs
cela d'ailleurs recoupe une autre
disposition deviendrait un peu plus tard
et cette disposition a été déposée par
un certain nombre de présidents de
groupe qui vise à faire en sorte que les
collaborateurs des groupes puissent
également participé au travail des
commissions
à notre avis cela ne relève pas de la
compétence du règlement mais cela relève
d instruction générale du bureau qui
pourrons à ce moment là faire en sorte
de prévoir dans quelles conditions les
commissions pourrait s'ouvrir aux
collaborateurs des milices pourraient
sauver en collaborateurs des groupes
pour s ouvrait un vin tellement à
d'autres personnes ou pour
éventuellement faire l'objet d'une
rediffusion à la télévision la
l'efficacité dans l'organisation du
travail des commissions apparaît
naturellement également dans la
précision apportée au nom des
commissions à l'article 4 dans les
nominations des membres des commissions
à l'article 10 dans ses pouvoirs
d'évaluation et de contrôle à l'article
11 ou dans la publication des projets de
loi des propositions de loi ainsi que
les modalités de dépôt de ceux ci à
l'article dose et à l'article 13 en ce
qui concerne la procédure accélérée
un mot sur la procédure de recevabilité
prévues aux articles 40 et 41 de la
constitution
nous aurons un débat tout à l'heure sur
cette question mais l'irrecevabilité de
l'article 40 que nous avons été amenés à
étendre non seulement en ce qui concerne
les projets de loi de finances mais
également les projets de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons naturellement accepté les
amendements de monsieur la selle est à
bout pour compléter le règlement ci
concerne justement les lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale par
contre il faut noter qu'il ya un progrès
dorénavant la commission saisie au fond
ou du moins son président pourront
déclarer l'irrecevabilité des
dispositions qui porterait atteinte à
l'article 40 de la constitution s'il y
ajoute le président de la commission
saisie au fond pourra saisir la
commission des finances qui à ce
moment-là pourra intervenir il ya
toujours un risque naturellement qu'il
pourrait se produire c'est un désaccord
entre la commission saisie au fond et la
commission des finances en séance
publique
mais cela éventuellement pour être
facilement résolu puisque c'est ce qui
se passe
à l'heure actuelle en ce qui concerne
l'article 41 il n'y a pas beaucoup de
changements l'article 41 c'est le
président de notre assemblée où le
gouvernement qui pourront décider de
l'irrecevabilité
s'il ya désaccord entre les deux le
conseil constitutionnel sera sam en a
six deuxième élément de souplesse et
d'efficacité de transparence
c'est dans le calendrier aidant les
aurez vous noterez en relisant les
dispositions de la résolution qu'il est
prévu un certain nombre d'horaires mais
en principe c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
pas établir une règle permanente pérenne
puisque il ya en permanence des
chevauchements il se perd entre les
horaires des commissions des groupes de
travail de la séance plénière et cetera
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
consacré le mardi matin au bureau et aux
réunions des groupes
en principe c'est l'article 3 les
commissions se réunissent en principe le
mercredi matin c'est l'article 8 la
commission des affaires européennes
et ça c'est une nouveauté par rapport au
texte initial
la délégation aux droits des femmes et à
l'égalité des chances se réunira en
dehors des moments où se réunit
l'assemblée plénière l'organisation de
l'ordre du jour est fixé à l'article 16
je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
ainsi que l'organisation des débats
toujours gelé dit également tout à
l'heure et je l'article 17 prévoit
l'organisation des discussions générales
et les horaires de séances sont
également prévus je précise le mardi le
mercredi le jeudi matin après midi et
soir
il n'est pas question dans notre
règlement du lundi ou du vendredi je
précise ce sera la conférence des
présidents qui en décidera comme
d'habitude et comme toujours par contre
j'ai une interrogation j'ai pas voulu
l'approfondir en rédigeant les un
certain nombre d'amendements
je ne sais pas quand ça s'arrête le soir
est ce que le soir s'arrête au moment où
on ferme
grilles du jardin du luxembourg ou
est-ce qu'au contraire le soir se
prolonge jusqu'à minuit même peut-être
au dollar c'est une question que je
laisse à votre approbation dans le
calendrier dans les horaires je rappelle
que le temps de présentation des
amendements prévus à l'article 24
la grande innovation la grande nouveauté
sera que les présentateurs d'amendements
disposeront à l'avenir non pas de cinq
minutes comme c'est le cas à l'heure
actuelle mais de trois minutes pour
présenter leurs amendements par contre
l'intervention sur un article sur un
amendement ou les explications de vote
continueront de s'exercer pendant cinq
minutes
je rappelle également que les
dispositions qui permettent de discuter
en priorité sur le texte de la
commission ne s'applique pas à certaines
catégories de loi qui sont les lois
constitutionnelles les lois de finances
et lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale où on continue de travailler sur
le texte venue du gouvernement en
priorité également quelques nouveautés
de transparence et d'efficacité
concernant l'article 27 sur
l'information et l'autorisation du
parlement en matière d'intervention des
troupes à l'étranger
ou alors le très longue
article 28 qui permet de faire face aux
nouvelles compétences de la commission
des affaires européennes et de faire
face à l'adoption des résolutions en
matière européenne je reviendrai le cas
échéant lors de la discussion sur cet
article m en fin d'article 30 concerne
le budget les comptes du sénat
l'encore je reviendrai sur cette
question car un amendement important
sera présenté à cette occasion
c'est donc après cette présentation
rapide
c'est donc quelque chose d'important que
nous allons faire aujourd'hui le
règlement que je vous présente est un
règlement très libérale qui
pourrait parfaitement satisfaire nos
voisins britanniques
mais c'est un règlement qui devra pour
être efficace être correctement
appliquée il faudra en permanence que
les différents responsables des groupes
politiques et les parlementaires
eux-mêmes respectent leurs adversaires
et respecte un minimum de fair play dans
le déroulement et l'organisation des
débats
il faudra en permanence avoir cette
volonté que si on ne veut pas que nos
débats s'enlisent et servent de mauvais
exemple eh bien il faudra que nous nous
auto discipline ion j'ajoute à cela
qu'il faudra que le gouvernement se
discipline aussi parce qu'il faudra que
le gouvernement évite de nous mettre des
loi fourre tout des lois trop longue et
se limite à des lois courte parce qu'une
loi courte signifie peu d'amendements
tandis qu'une loi longue signifie en
moyenne 10 amendements par article si
vous avez 100 articles et bien vous
aurez au moins 1000 amendements et donc
nous aurons à ce moment là un
déroulement considérable il faudra aussi
que l'on apprenne peut être aller plus
loin mais cela viendra lors du rendez
vous que nous nous sommes fixés l'année
prochaine sous l'autorité du président
du sénat pour re voir dans quelle mesure
la commission pourra devenir un peu plus
le lieu où on devra discuter en
profondeur véritablement les
modifications législatives et où la
science publique sera un peu réduite
dans son action et dans son activité
mais à ce moment là il faudra repenser
peut-être la totalité la disposition de
nos salles de réunion il faudra sans
doute repenser totalement les modalités
de publicité des travaux de nos
commissions
c'est un gros travail pour les années à
venir alors après ces quelques remarques
que je viens de vous présenter je
voudrais conclure
j'avais commencé en vous parlant d'une
musique qu'il fallait faire sur les
paroles d'une chanson
vous connaissez maintenant la musique je
viens de vous la présenter
tout dépendra maintenant des interprètes
c'est à dire de nous mêmes
ou bien la musique que nous aurons
composé sera harmonieuse
ou bien ce sera une abominable
cacophonie encore faudra-t-il qu'elles
soient audibles par la population
française par le gouvernement et par
tous ceux qui suivent nos travaux merci
monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
jean jacques hyest président de la
commission des lois et du règlement
d'ailleurs vous avez la parole monsieur
le président merci monsieur le président
la proposition de résolution que nous
examinons aujourd'hui à l'initiative de
vous même monsieur le président c'est
suite à une réflexion approfondie menée
au sein d'un groupe de travail où tous
les groupes de la tra semble étaient
représentés et qui ont pu aboutir un
large consensus
même si l'opposition de certains à la
révision constitutionnelle ne leur
permettrait pas d approuver totalement
notre démarche chez le président j'ai eu
plaisir bien sûr de rapporter cette
révision ainsi que et ainsi que mon
excellent collègue bernard frimat qui a
participé autant que moi à l'élaboration
de ce texte
ben oui
bah mais monsieur mercier vous avez
participé aussi beaucoup aux débats
je rappelle je rappelle que tous les
groupes politiques étaient représentés
au sein du groupe de travail et que
chacun a participé pour élaborer ce
consensus même si ça n'a pas abouti
totalement en ce qui concerne la
présidente borvo et le groupe et son
gros il s'agit de mettre en oeuvre bien
sûr la révision constitutionnelle de
conforter le pluralisme sénatoriales et
de rénover nos méthodes de travail
à cet égard les biens sur la totalité du
règlement n'a pu n'a pas été modifié
car nos pratiques actuelles était
satisfaisante même si nous avons un
rendez vous dans un an pour déterminer
si la révision constitutionnelle et ses
conséquences
quand je parle de ses conséquences c'est
bien entendu la loi organique et sans
oublier bien sûr maintenant une loi
organique une constitution ça ne suffit
plus en heure en eux mêmes
il faut ajouter les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel soit par des considérant
comme ça soit bien sûr par la manière
dont tino z
le conseil constitutionnel nous indique
comment nous devons appliquer la
constitution
il ya une thèse à faire sur le conseil
constitutionnel est le vrai constituant
et bien sûr nous serons peut être amenés
à modifier certaines dispositions autres
celles qui nous sont proposées
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne la mise
en oeuvre de la révision
constitutionnelle je crois qu'il faut
rappeler le rôle central de la
conférence des présidents pour
l'organisation de travaux et c'est
pourquoi le règlement comme l'indiquait
le rapporteur doit rester un cadre
souple et adaptable
c'est notamment le cas en ce qui
concerne la nouvelle procédure de
clôture des débats
qui est cet heureux précédé d'un
dialogue au sein de la conférence des
présidents
s'agissant du pluralisme sénatoriales la
résolution entend bien affirmer les
droits des groupes parlementaires et des
droits spécifiques des groupes
d'opposition est minoritaire
monsieur le président mercier article 51
1 de la constitution en dehors mais ça
sert aussi à melbourne beau mais c'est
vous qui avez fait la promotion des
comptes minoritaire en dehors de la
journée deux séances mensuelles réserver
des droits spécifiques des groupes
d'opposition est minoritaire
l'article 51 1 et je le rappelle
d'ailleurs que c'est rappeler à
l'article 48
la composition du bureau du sénat
le respect du pluralisme d'un
désignation des représentants du sénat
au sein des organismes
extraparlementaires la désignation des
membres dcmp le droit de tirage pour les
commissions d'enquêté l'émission
d'information constitue une illustration
de cette volonté de permettre à tous de
participer à la fois la vie notre
assemblée mais d'affirmer les droits de
l'opposition et des groupes minoritaires
à condition bien sûr mes chers collègues
que leur nombre soit significatif et
d'ailleurs comme le dit un éminent
président il n'ya que des groupes
minoritaires ici et oui hein
alors peut-être qu'on pourra en déduire
un certain nombre de choses restent les
questions importantes à savoir
l'organisation de débats qu'il s'agisse
de la séance publique où des commissions
il était apparu sans doute naïvement que
pour la rationalisation de notre travail
parlementaire
le fait de délibérer en séance sur le
texte proposé par la commission devrait
contribuer à concentrer sur l'essentiel
le débat en séance publique
surtout si l'examen d'un texte est
précédé d'un débat préalable
d'orientation prévu par notre règlement
et souhaitait vivement par le président
de raku ça ne le fait pas ça ne fait pas
bouger une oreille bon
à la lumière des premières expériences
et pour tenir compte du fait que le
droit d'amendement s'exerce en séance ou
en commission
nous n'avons peut-être pas trouvé
l'équilibré souhaité la meilleure
publicité des travaux des commissions ce
qui ne signifie pas leur caractère
public systématique publicité ne veut
pas dire séance publique
et lors de la mise à disposition plus
rapide et plus complète de leurs travaux
devraient permettre de mieux connaître
le travail des commissions à nos
collègues et à l'extérieur et sont
certainement un des enjeux de la réforme
mais je sais monsieur le président que
vous allez prendre tous les moyens avec
le bureau pour permettre cette meilleure
cette amélioration de la qualité du
travail des commissions
je ne reviendrai pas sur l'incidence de
la présence des ministres en commission
déduite par le conseil constitutionnel
du fait que nous délibérons séance sur
le texte proposé par la commission ce
qui nous oblige à modifier l'article 8
du règlement
je ne suis pas sûr que leur présence
permanente et bien entendu et savait
seulement pour l'élaboration du texte de
la commission
en dehors de cela les ministres n'ont
pas à être là sauf si nous souhaitons
les entendre soit de nature à simplifier
nos débats heureuse commission des
finances monsieur le président arthuis
ou heureuse commission des affaires
sociales
monsieur le président avoue d'ailleurs
sur l'un à côté de l'autre un puisque
vous n'avez pas cette obligation d'avoir
des ministres ni pour le budget ni pour
les lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale
alors nous partageons cela la commission
des lois mais j'ai l'impression quand
même quelque part qu' une nouvelle
révision constitutionnelle n'est pas
pour demain matin
au delà de la réforme de notre règlement
nous pouvons nous interroger
nous pouvons nous interroger sur la
revalorisation affirmé du rôle du
parlement que nous avons soutenu pas
tous mais que nous avons soutenue
notamment en ce qui concerne l'ordre du
jour partagé et bien entendu ce qui est
tout à fait naturel
la volonté d'engager des réformes sur
lequel le président de la république et
la majorité parlementaire se sont
engagés si on empêche totalement une
majorité de faire les réformes sur
lequel elle s'est engagée vous avouerez
que ça serait une curieuse de démocratie
nous avions indiqué que cela risquait de
conduire à une impasse
sauf engagement systématique de la
procédure d'urgence dite accélérée
nous avons encore à trouver un équilibre
et nous le voyons bien depuis quelques
semaines
certes mais c'est la tradition du sénat
conforté par la révision
constitutionnelle la fonction de
contrôle du parlement sur l'action
contre berne au mental doit continuer à
se développer et on a fait beaucoup de
travaux dans cette maison sans vraiment
les faire connaître à condition que cela
ne devienne pas un rite vide de réel
contenu et fasse l'objet d'une réelle
préparation en amont en amont dans le
temps le rôle des commissions est
essentiel dans ce domaine comme les
rôles des groupes comme force de
proposition
l'initiative législative doit aussi or
les droits des groupes d'opposition est
minoritaire que j'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure s'inscrire dans la durée pour
éviter d'être anecdotique mais monsieur
le président mes chers collègues on le
voit bien
et ce devrait être le souci permanent
tant du gouvernement que du parlement la
sécurité juridique
comme une saine application des articles
34 et 37 de la constitution sont un
petit peu absent de nos travaux
l'inflation législative tant par le
nombre de textes par leur longueur et
l'important intec ne se mesure pas
toujours au nombre d'articles
d'ajournement sur le fonctionnement du
parlement pèse lourdement
mais en fait ça n'est pas nouveau et je
vous cite je vous donnerai trois
citations 3 les lois inutiles
affaiblissent et noah nécessaire
montesquieu normalement la loi devrait
uniquement permettre ordonné ou
interdire et puis la plus belle c'est
celle de montagne dans les essais nous
avons en france plus de lois que le
reste du monde ensemble et plus qu'il
n'en faudrait pour à régler tous les
mondes des piqûres qu'on gagne et de
législateurs à choisir 100 mille espèces
effets particuliers et à y attacher
100000 lois les plus désirables se passe
ce sont les plus rares simple et général
puissions-nous dans l'avenir nous
référer à ces grands auteurs
merci monsieur le président dans la nuit
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est maintenant aux présidents
bernard frimat
je peux donc vous avez la parole
monsieur le président c'est le président
et cher collègue revaloriser le
parlement
le doter de poule voire nouveau tel
était selon son auteur l'objet est
l'ambition de la révision
constitutionnelle à grand renfort de
communication ce message a été martelé
pour qu'ils entrent bien dans la tête de
nos concitoyens que n'at-on entendu de
la bouche de constitutionnalistes
forcément éminents et de commentateurs
naturellement avisés pour condamner
l'attitude de ces parlementaires qui
avaient l'outrecuidance de ne pas
joindre leur foi au concert de louanges
organisée pour célébrer cette grande
réforme institutionnelle qu'en est il de
cette supposée modernisation de nos
institutions qui peut prétendre que dans
la pratique de son fonctionnement
quotidien
le parlement a été revalorisé et que les
parlementaires disposent de nouveaux
pouvoirs
nous avions dénoncé l'avènement d'une
monocratie la poursuite du renforcement
de l'exécutif le caractère trompeur est
illusoire des pouvoirs donnés au
parlement laissez nous donne
indiscutablement raison les lois
organiques révélatrice des réelles
intentions du gouvernement
simple porte voix de la majorité
présidentielle sont venus confirmer le
caractère fondé de nos craintes
avant toute chose il fallait ce fut
l'objet de la première loi organique
votée conforme par le sénat mettre en
oeuvre les facilités dans le
gouvernement avait besoin d'abord
organisé en cas de cessation de fonction
le retour des ministres anciennement
parlementaires dans leur assemblée
d'origine la nomination
au secrétaire général de l'ump de xavier
bertrand exigé de régler rapidement
cette grande avancée démocratique
ce qui fut fait ensuite arrêté la
composition de la commission chargée
d'émettre un avis public sur le
découpage des circonscriptions pour
l'élection des députés
aucune garantie de pluralisme n'a été
mis en place à cette occasion
au contraire la nomination son président
par le président de la république
renforce les doutes sur la réalité son
indépendance en ce1 il fallait autoriser
le gouvernement à procéder par voie
d'ordonnancé ce découpage afin de
permettre à monsieur marc l'ex de
montrer l'étendue de ce hit talent il
faut me chers collègues beaucoup
d'optimisme pour qualifier d' extension
du pouvoir du parrot du parlement le
recours aux ordonnances
il faut beaucoup de naïveté pour voir la
manifestation d'une démocratie
irréprochable dans un découpage dans le
caractère injuste et partisan de plus en
plus patent semble faire peu de cas au
demeurant des réserves émises par le
conseil constitutionnel qui insistent et
sur la priorité à donner à l' équilibre
démographique rien dans cette première
loi organique n'est venu revaloriser le
parlement lors de la révision les
zélateurs du projet avait beaucoup
disserté sur la limitation volontaire
que le président de la république avait
souhaité s'imposer à propos de son
pouvoir de nomination il glorifier la
capacité de contestation ainsi donné au
parlement
comme nous l'avions dit à l'époque ce
pouvoir est factice c'est un faux
semblant
un trompe l'oeil puisque il faut réunir
une majorité des 3/5 pour refuser le
choix du président et donc que la
majorité parlementaire entre en conflit
avec le président ce qui est une vue de
l'esprit
en revanche ce qui n'est pas factice
c'est la volonté du président
d'augmenter le champ
de son pouvoir de nomination la loi sur
l'audiovisuel est là pour en témoigner
dans le processus de nomination de jean
luc hees et didier n'a le parlement a pu
vérifier que sont supposés pouvoirs
étaient inexistants la loi organique
relative au fonctionnement même du
parlement et la pratique du gouvernement
depuis le début de la session ordinaire
ont enlevé et dernières illusions des
parlementaires qui était qui c'était de
bonne foi laissé convaincre ou séduire
par le discours présidentiel sur des
droits nouveaux du parlement là où l'on
nous avait annoncé un progrès
significatif
le constat s'impose d'un recul
démocratique important dans les faits
messire collègues la navette
parlementaire a été supprimé et le
dialogue entre les deux heures semblait
voué à la quasi disparition puisqu'il se
limite aux seuls membres des commissions
mixtes paritaires le recours
systématique à la procédure d'urgence
hier a été remplacé par un recours tout
aussi systématique à la procédure
accélérée
pourtant lors des débats sur la révision
il avait été fait sur tous les bancs le
constat que le recours trop fréquent à
l'urgence nuisait au bon fonctionnement
du parlement et à l'élaboration des
textes de l'oat qualité nous avions
d'ailleurs proposer une limitation
quantitative de l'urgence met la charrue
ma la majorité avaient préféré
privilégier un changement sémantique qui
supprime et l'urgence et le remplacer
par la procédure accélérée
la novation consisté dans la possibilité
donnée aux deux conférences des
présidents de s'opposer par décision
identique à la mise en oeuvre de cette
procédure je crains que là encore il ne
s'agit d'une liberté formelle car sa
concrétisation signifierait un conflit
entre la majorité parlementaire et le
président de la république qui de fait
défini les projets de loi
prenons date mais alors armons nous
d'une infinie patience
pour attendre la première mise en échec
de la procédure accélérée
le parlement n'est plus pour le
président le lieu d'expression par la
loi de la souveraineté du peuple
il est vécu comme un frein comme un
obstacle à la réalisation rapide des
annonces présidentielles
celle-ci fusse-t-elle contradictoires
doivent trouver leur traduction
législative le plus rapidement possible
on constate d'ailleurs que dans
plusieurs cas la loi a été mise en
application avant même d'avoir été votée
alors que dans le même temps certaines
lois votées qui n'ont plus leur de
plaire ne sont pas appliquées quel
mépris pour les travaux des
parlementaires
quand nos collègues députés réclament
que la loi hôpital reviennent en seconde
lecture devant l'assemblée nationale
ils ont raison dans une situation
analogue nous effectuions la même
demande
la priorité absolue pour le gouvernement
et d'avancer le plus vite possible
ainsi à la procédure accélérée s'ajoute
la multiplication des séances de nuit
la programmation de plus en plus
habituel des séances le lundi et le
vendredi
la schiste et matt isation des sessions
extraordinaires qui non plus
d'extraordinaire que le nom puisqu'elle
sont devenus au mois de juillet notre
ordinaire et que septembre semble
appelée à connaître le même sort
ce qui est j'ai souvent les chiffres
légiférer vite sous le regard permanent
du gouvernement
limiter le droit d'amendement tenter de
réduire le temps du débat parlementaire
en séance publique
telle est la pratique du gouvernement
nous sommes mes chers collègues bien
loin de la revalorisation du parlement
qui peut présenter comme un progrès
comme un droit nouveau pour le parlement
la possibilité pour le gouvernement
s'ils le souhaitent d'être présent de
manière permanente en commission certes
le gouvernement doit pouvoir se faire
entendre quand il le veut
mais une fois qu'il s'est exprimée ne
peut-il laisser les parlementaires
travailler entre eux à l'élaboration du
texte de la com
dot hill à ce point de sa majorité qu'il
ait besoin de la mettre sous
surveillance constante
si nous voulons rendre à la séance
publique tout son intérêt ne doit-elle
pas être le lieu où se confrontent avant
décision
les positions du gouvernement de la
commission et des groupes politiques là
où la démocratie exige la séparation des
pouvoirs la pratique du gouvernement
introduit la confusion des pouvoirs
le gouvernement a décidé de permettre
l'instauration du temps global dans le
débat parlementaire
alors que rien ne l'y obligeait il a
choisi de rendre possible la situation
un parlementaire ne pourra pas descendre
l'amendement dont il est l'auteur est
donc tenté de convaincre ses collègues
du bien fondé de sa proposition
la révision constitutionnelle censée
augmenter les droits du parlementaire
pourra donc aboutir à priver celui-ci de
la plénitude du droit d'amendement
quel paradoxe ou plutôt quel aveu sur la
réalité de cette révision
même si le sénat n'instaure pas le temps
global ce dont nous réjouissons la
possibilité de le voir un jour instauré
demeure nous avons le président voté
contre la révision constitutionnelle
nous avons voté contre les lois
organiques nous sommes aujourd'hui
saisie de votre proposition de
modification du règlement du sénat qui
n'a d'autre choix que de respecter la
constitution les lois organiques et la
récente décision du conseil
constitutionnel
ce règlement comporte par conséquent des
aspects que nous ne pouvons approuver
pour élaborer votre proposition vous
avez mis en place monsieur le président
une commission de travail à laquelle les
sénateurs du groupe socialiste ont
participé sans réticence en prenant
pleinement leur part au débat le texte
dont je ne reprendrai pas le contenu que
présenter patrice gélard de manière
fidèle exhaustive au nom de la
commission des loi comporte quelques
points de divergence et aussi de
nouveaux points d'accord qui ont
recueilli l'avis unanime des
participants de la commission vous avez
présidé un désaccord importants
subsistent
toutefois entre nous il tient à la
volonté de la majorité d'exclure
l'opposition de toutes les présidences
de commission néanmoins le texte que
vous nous proposez constituer ce
président un point équilibre compte tenu
des rapports de force politiques
existant dans notre assemblée et un
indiscutable progrès par rapport à un
règlement actuel le groupe socialiste a
voulu le signifier en ne déposant pas
d'amendement la commission des lois à
améliorer certaines rédactions et
préciser quelques incertitudes mais elle
a respecté le point d'équilibré qui
avait été trouvé
votre proposition monsieur le président
reconnaît par une application à la
répartition des postes à la
proportionnelle au plus fort reste des
droits à chaque groupe politique
elle abandonne ainsi la pratique
antérieure qui subordonnait la place des
groupes d'opposition au bon vouloir de
la majorité
c'est une avancée dans le fonctionnement
démocratique de notre assemblée
enfin et c'est fondamental le temps
globalisé ne fera pas instaurer au sénat
c'est un acquis essentiel pour le groupe
socialiste que chaque sénateur
qu'ils soient de la majorité ou de
l'opposition puisse bénéficie en séance
publique de la plénitude de sa capacité
d'intervention pour ces différentes
raisons et en me réjouissant du climat
de dialogue qui a présidé aux travaux
sur le règlement du sénat je conclurai
monsieur le président en réaffirmant que
les sénateurs socialistes ne
s'opposeront pas à votre proposition
mais qu'ils choisiront si le scrutin est
public de déposer un bulletin rouge
6 merci monsieur le président la parole
est maintenant au président michel
mercier
seul la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues sont donc amenés à débattre
aujourd'hui de votre proposition
monsieur le président qui vise à
réformer le règlement du sénat et à
introduire dans notre règlement les
conséquences de la réforme
constitutionnelle est ainsi que celle
des lois organiques qui ont été votées
et depuis il reste d'ailleurs un certain
nombre à voter qu'il faudra bien voter
le plus rapidement possible pour que la
réforme constitutionnelle prenne tout
son sens et je pense notamment à la loi
organique relative au contrôle de
constitutionnalité qui ouvrira à nos
concitoyens un champ nouveau de droit et
qui ne réservera pas qu aux élus
parlementaires les droits nouveaux
je voudrais simplement faire part de
quelques observations
d'abord sur les apports globaux que l'on
peut trouver dans la proposition qui
nous est faite aujourd'hui que notre
rapporteur
le rapporteur a parfaitement sains
rappeler que l'on pourrait classer sous
la rubrique un plus pour le pluralisme
au sénat et c'est vrai et qu'il y à un
certain nombre de dispositions qui vont
dans ce sens qui est le bon sens je
voudrais rappeler est tout d'abord la
répartition à la proportionnelle des
responsabilités au sein du bureau du
sénat
le changement très important fondamental
de la conférence des présidents
avec un mode de votation qui représente
exactement la composition du sénat et je
crois que cela est quelque chose de tout
à fait un capital qui changera
profondément les habitudes de cette
maison qui petit à petit fera de la
conférence des présidents
l'organe politique qui préparera les
débats de notre assemblée
il y a bien sûr tout ce qui concerne
également les droits des groupes
minoritaires et des groupes de
l'opposition
s'agissant des groupes minoritaires
je connais mieux de dire que jusqu'à
maintenant ces droits sont surtout
inscrit dans les textes et qu'il reste à
le faire entrer dans les habitudes et
dans les fêtes
j'espère que l'on y parviendra au fil du
temps des discussions est qui seront les
nôtres mais est il reste à certain
nombre de points sur lesquels je
voudrais revenir et qui ont trait plus
largement à l'organisation de travaux
législatifs et on peut regarder on peut
regarder bien sûr ces propositions qui
nous sont faites par rapport aux
expériences que nous sommes en train de
vivre sur la loi hôpital ou sur d'autres
textes
tout d'abord je veux noté et je remercie
le rapporteur d'avoir rappelé le cadre
dans lequel il a travaillé c'est que
tout ce qui concerne l'organisation de
travaux législatifs résultent d'un
accord entre les deux co rapporteurs du
groupe de travail c'est ce qu'a dit
monsieur le rapporteur chien doté il a
dit qu'il avait pris que des amendements
qui pouvaient s'inscrire dans les
conclusions des deux co rapporteurs
je cite monsieur j'ai l'air si je me
suis trompé mais ce genr me le dira mais
que le président vous pouvez m'interroge
quand vous voulez surtout que je n'ai
pas terminé sur ce chapitre là alors
allez-y avec l'autorisation du président
mercier sans problème président y est
les co-rapporteurs n'étant que les porte
paroles de ce qui avait été fait dans le
groupe de travail il portait déjà leurs
paroles à eux
non mais j'attendais monsieur monsieur
mercier vous le savez fort bien
c'est ce qui est en nous avons rapporté
en fonction du consensus sur un certain
nombre de sujets dont le vôtre
d'ailleurs votre consensus aussi sur un
certain nombre de sujets simplement on
n'a pas mis notre grain de sel dans
cette danse est
résolution voilà donc cision sur les
princesses décisions essentielles
je voudrais préciser ce qu'est à mon
sentiment
le projet sur le travail législatif et
la séance c'est le résultat d'un accord
entre les deux principaux groupes de
notre assemblée que des choses ont été
faites dans ce domaine à et qu'il faut
bien avoir le courage de le reconnaître
et de l'assumer et j'espère que tous
ceux qui ont réalisé ce travail irons au
bout des choses en le votant
sinon c'est pas la peine si on ne va pas
et je peux bien dire ce que je veux
quand je suis ici la parole est libre
monsieur bell mais vous dire après ce
que vous voulez je constate donc que sur
un certain nombre de points notamment
sur l'organisation de l'agenda
parlementaire
notre groupe n'a pas été associée de
président ça a été la sphère des deux
principaux groupes et que c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs un des points sur
lequel il faudra revenir dans les mois
ou les années qui viennent quand on
regarde la façon dont se déroulent les
travaux parlementaires aujourd'hui que
l'on essaye de faire un agenda de dire
que les commissions siégeront tel jour à
telle heure que la séance publique aura
lieu tel jour à telle heure d suffit de
regarder et de voir que les choses
fonctionnent comme avant que nous
n'avons pas pu changer et qu'il faut
faire face à au travail législatif tel
qu'il est et que le consensus qui a été
recherché et je suis favorable au
consensus
par nature a abouti à un résultat
inachevé il faut bien qu'on ne
reconnaisse et que nous aurons encore à
travailler pour trouver et à construire
pour trouver le bon niveau de
fonctionnement du sauna avec la
nécessité de conserver toutes les
libertés et tous les droits pour chacun
des sénateurs mais aussi
de pouvoir avancer dans les débats et de
faire progresser les discussions
nous avons je crois une grande chance
c'est que le président du sénat vous
nous avez offert de travailler de façon
pluraliste ensemble moi je souhaite
simplement soit un peu plus pluraliste
mais c'est un choix personnel
je réitère ici mais ce souhait
travaillent ensemble doit aboutir aussi
à un travail efficace du sénat est un
travail le plus facile impossible pour
tous
c'est vrai que nous n'avons pas su
répondre à toutes les questions d'emploi
du temps nous le voyons bien je crois
qu'il faut avoir pleinement conscience
savoir qu'il faudra qu'on retravaille
sur ce règlement mais qu' aujourd'hui la
proposition qui nous est faite est une
proposition qui nous permet d'avancer
d'aller de l'avant et d'aller de l'avant
comme il convient dans une assemblée
parlementaire
c'est à dire sur la base du consensus le
plus large possible
alors c'est la raison pour laquelle même
si notre groupe ne se sent pas l'auteur
de toutes les propositions qui sont
faites aujourd'hui bien il assumera ces
propositions et celle des autres en
votant la proposition qui nous est faite
merci monsieur le président la parole
est maintenant à madame la présidente
nicole borvo cohen seat
vous avez la parole mme la présidente
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
alors monsieur le président le groupe de
travail sénatorial que vous avez mis en
place en octobre dernier pour préparer
la réforme du règlement dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui à travailler
sérieusement sans aucun doute donc je
peux confirmer ce qu'on dit mes
prédécesseurs mais je précise cela ne
vaut pas consensus sur le résultat le
règlement procède de la révision
constitutionnelle et de la loi organique
du 15 avril 2009 contre lesquelles nous
avons voté parce que nous contestons le
fait que son contenu renforce le rôle du
parlement le débat sur la loi organique
a été tout à fait significatif
la majorité ump a fait le choix
d'inscrire dans la loi organique la
limitation possible a priori du débat
public au parlement
le créditant le fait que dans le même
temps le groupe de travail du sénat ne
retiennent pas cette disposition pour
son propre règlement n'a pas empêché ne
vous a pas empêché de voter cette
limitation dans la loi organique
l'assemblée nationale l'a bien inscrit
dans son règlement est d'ailleurs le
débat à l'assemblée nationale a pris une
bien curieuse tournure si on en croit
les échanges à l'intérieur même de la
majorité sur le règlement de l'assemblée
nationale le président l'assemblée
nationale en est venu à défendre ni
équilibre entre majorité et opposition
entre exécutif et majorité entre
exécutif et parlement chacun peut
interpréter tandis que le président de
son groupe lui oppose le fait
majoritaire et le refus de toute
inflexion du crédit temps et comme
xavier bertrand aujourd'hui secrétaire
général de l'ump là pour rappeler que la
légitimité de la majorité parlementaire
surtout des députés précise-t-il
provient du président de la république
la boucle est bouclée ceci confirme
encore une fois que la révision
constitutionnelle et la pratique qui l'a
d'ailleurs précédé et inspiré nous
conduit à une situation très
préoccupante
un pouvoir exécutif concentré dans les
mains du président de la république chef
de la majorité
parti majoritaire de la majorité et
président omnipotent et omniprésent un
parlement largement réduit au bavardage
en effet le parlement peu en dehors de
la discussion des projets de lois
débattre de sujets créer des missions
les parlementaires passe beaucoup de
temps en commission que le gouvernement
supervise on à l'inspection des travaux
finis par des contrôles multiples sans
grande de suite
en même temps il ne se passe pas une
semaine sans que le président de la
république n'annonce de nouvelles
dispositions à venir au rythme des faits
divers des échéances électorales et des
sondages de sur sa popularité il crée
des commission ad-hoc missionne telle ou
telle personnalité de son choix
le parlement éventuellement étudie la
question avec sa propre mission pour
préparer ou tester ces de testing
présidentielle l'opinion et voir comment
faire passer la loi sur la sécurité
intérieure adopté vendredi dernier en
conseil des ministres n'est-elle pas la
troisième du genre depuis 2002 trop de
lois tuent la loi chacun ici a dû le
dire au moins une fois dans sa vie
parlementaire et monsieur le rapporteur
viens de le dire mais vous continuez tel
un troupeau au bord du ravin
l'inflation législative génère
l'utilisation à répétition de la
procédure d'urgence devenue accéléré que
nous critiquons en ce qui nous concerne
depuis 1958 ainsi et est il sérieux de
déclarer et maintenir l'urgence sur la
loi pénitentiaire votée ici en 2009 et
pas encore inscrite à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale est il sérieux de
maintenir l'urgence sur l'hôpital qui
verra l'assemblée nationale élue au
suffrage universel direct
privé de l'examen d'un texte réécrit de
manière importante même si le
gouvernement a repris les choses en main
comme le dit si élégamment à l'égard du
sénat monsieur accoyer
il faut également rappeler qu'en cas de
procédures accélérées l'une des rares
avancées de la révision
constitutionnelle c'est à dire un délai
obligatoire entre le dépôt d'un projet
de loi et son examen en séance publique
n'est plus applicable
même cause même effet sur le fameux
partage de l'ordre du jour nous en
voyons les premiers résultats
soit on accepte un débat étriqué sur les
projets de loi d'origine gouvernementale
le parlement ne disposant pas du temps
nécessaire pour jouer son rôle de
législateur soit il c'est de son ordre
du jour au gouvernement comme cela s'est
fait plusieurs fois l'assemblée
nationale et comme cela se fait en ce
moment même au sénat avec la loi sur
l'hôpital
monsieur le président il n'était pas
sérieux d'annoncer cette nouvelle
répartition de l'ordre du jour sans
s'affranchir de l'inflation législative
du gouvernement qui non seulement rend
le respect peu crédible mais recycle les
projets de loi en propositions de la
majorité
je note évidemment que la commission des
lois a rejeté notre amendement tendant à
interdire que la répartition de l'ordre
du jour puissent être modifiés en cours
de route
et ce n'est pas anticonstitutionnel
comme le dit notre rapporteur
sous-entendant que nos amendements sont
forcément en type consiste
constitutionnel autre pilier de la
révision constitutionnelle l'orientation
vers la commission du travail du débat
parlementaire
nous avons exprimé clairement et sans
hésitation
notre opposition à cette évolution le
travail en commission présentée comme la
quintessence du travail parlementaire
revêt à nos yeux deux défauts majeurs
l'absence de transparence et la
minoration du pluralisme
ces défauts met en valeur deux qualités
tout aussi majeur de la séance publique
la transparence et un cadre d'expression
du pluralisme
les premières semaines d'application de
la révision constitutionnelle depuis le
1er mars débouche sur un premier constat
pour faire fonctionner le nouveau
système il faut soit appliquée la
réduction du droit d'amendement et du
débat public voie choisie par
l'assemblée nationale soit accepter une
certaine confusion entre travail en
commissions et séance publique la
présence des ministres en cours des
délibérés au cours des délibérations et
du vote en commission que vous avez
accepté bien que vous soyez opposez vous
y soyez opposé ne fait qu'aggraver une
véritable confusion des pouvoirs
d'ailleurs ça mériterait plus ample
débat sur le respect de la séparation
des pouvoirs
je note que la commission des lois a
refusé notre amendement tendant à
limiter cette collaboration entre
ministres et parlementaires au sein des
commissions et ce ne serait point
anticonstitutionnelle monsieur le
président nous ne méconnaissons pas le
parti pris au sénat de tempérer le fait
majoritaire
l'existence d'une majorité relative de
l'ump aujourd'hui dans cette assemblée
il est peut-être pour quelque chose mais
qui peut croire un instant que le sénat
qui va décider de ne pas appliquer le
crédit temps ce qui est en soi une bonne
chose pourra continuer longtemps à
débattre de manière plus démocratique et
approfondie alors que l'assemblée
nationale sera en permanence sous le
coup du 49-3 parlementaire comme je lé
déjà appelé au moment de la révision
constitutionnelle c'est à dire la
limitation du temps de parole global par
la conférence des présidents
j'espère me tromper en discernant un
prétexte dans l'attitude de la majorité
sénatoriale pour mieux valider la fin du
débat démocratique dans l'assemblée qui
a le dernier mot
monsieur le président nous avons
approuvé des modifications qui discutait
au comité sénatorial qui donne l égalité
au pluralisme en officialisant
l'application de la proportionnelle dans
les bureaux des commissions les
organismes l'ex frappèrent pas
parlementaire où la conférence des
présidents et en donnant quelques
reconnaissances au groupe
en application de l'article 51
1 de la constitution que nous avions
défendu concernant mon groupe mais ces
avancées sont très modestes est en
quelque sorte habilement contrainte
ainsi la commission des lois a refusé
qu'une demande de discussion immédiate
puisse être remise par un groupe au lieu
d'un nombre de sénateurs fixé à 30 comme
la majorité avait refusé que le conseil
constitutionnel puisse être saisi par un
groupe
la commission a refusé aussi notre
amendement tendant à inscrire le
principe d'un vice-président ou questeur
par groupe ce qui conforterait la
reconnaissance de chaque groupe
on nous oppose qui pourrait y avoir 12
groupes
je vous précise que c'est peut-être vrai
arithmétiquement ça me paraît difficile
politiquement par contre en refusant
notre amendement tendant à rendre
impossible le cumul davantage de la
majorité c'est à dire la présidence des
commissions et de droits de l'opposition
par exemple l'initiative mensuelles aux
groupes minoritaires qui ne se déclare
ni de l'une ni de l'autre
la commission entretient une confusion
regrettable
j'observe aussi que la commission a
rejeté deux amendements de mon groupe
sur des points qui semblait faire accord
dans le groupe de travail préliminaire
l'un pour prévoir que les débats de
procédure question préalable
irrecevabilité en commission ait lieu
avant la discussion générale comme c'est
le cas à l'assemblée nationale tout le
monde semblait ici considérés comme
absurde que les modes les motions de
procédure et lieu après la clôture de la
discussion générale
eh bien j'ai constaté que vous ne l'avez
pas retenu l'autre pour modifier la
vérification du quorum est d'ailleurs
que cette demande de quorum soit
possible pour un groupe ce qui encore
une fois été logique avec la
reconnaissance des groupes et surtout
pour rendre cette vérification du quorum
plus effective qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui
pour conclure je dirais que le sénat où
l'alternance n'a jusqu'ici jamais existé
a une longue expérience du fait
majoritaire et de la rationalisation des
débats par la majorité elle même
le règlement était déjà bien organisés
pour assurer à la majorité une parfaite
maîtrise du débat les demandes
suspension de séance et de quorum étant
beaucoup plus difficile à obtenir qu à
l'assemblée nationale le temps de parole
sur les motions de procédure et est
également beaucoup plus court ceux qui
ont déjà passé quelques années dans cet
hémicycle savent que les irrecevabilité
facilement utilisée pour supprimer de
nombreux amendements en cas de débats
tendus
je me rappelle comme beaucoup d'entre
vous à ce sujet le débat sur les
retraites en 2003 dans le contexte
actuel des rapports de force au sénat la
réforme qui nous est proposé aujourd'hui
se veut moins contraignante pour le
débat qu'à l'assemblée nationale elle ne
s'inscrit pas moins dans cette logique
de rationalisation du travail
parlementaire typiquement sénatoriales
depuis plus de vingt ans et que la
révision de 2008 a maintenant
constitutionnaliser l'extension du
domaine d irrecevabilité parlementaire
en matière financière au constitutionnel
la réduction du temps de parole
répondent à l'objectif du président de
la république de réduire de sans doute
de sa majorité le débat démocratique le
débat pluraliste et à une tendance
bipartiste des institutions alors que le
bipartisme est loin d'être une réalité
politique
nous voterons contre cette réforme du
règlement car elle s'inscrit pleinement
dans une révision constitutionnelle que
nous réfutons réfutons j'ajoute qu'une
éventuelle répartition des rôles entre
l'assemblée nationale le sénat que nous
n'acceptons pas où seuls les sages
pourraient débattre à volonté la chambre
émanant du suffrage universel direct et
en bâillonner ne nous convient pas non
plus nous espérons monsieur le président
que rapidement le constat sera fait du
danger que fait courir la loi
constitutionnelle de juillet dernier à
l' équilibre républicain et il faudra y
remédier sans tarder je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente la parole est
maintenant président henri de raincourt
la parole monsieur le président monsieur
le président mes chers collègues
modifier le règlement de notre assemblée
est à l'évidence un acte politique
c'est une nouvelle étape du chemin que
nous avons commencé à tracer en juillet
2008 en adoptant la plus importante
réforme constitutionnelle depuis 1958
dont l'objectif était d' accorder une
place plus grande aux parlements dans
l'élaboration de la loi et dans sa
capacité à contrôler et à évaluer
l'action gouvernementale s'est passé pas
si sûr
ses premiers changements sont entrées en
vigueur le 1er mars dernier avec le
partage de l'ordre du jour où la
discussion en séance du texte adopté par
la commission
l'étape d'aujourd'hui est une occasion
de moderniser notre loi intérieure
il ne faut pas la manquer sans pour
autant la fij et c'est la référence
indispensable pour l'organisation
pratique de nos travaux sur laquelle
chacun d'entre nous doit pouvoir
s'appuyer de sa teneur dépend en partie
la qualité de notre travail
le règlement c'est l'instrument d'
équilibre des pouvoirs
c'est le premier outil politique donnée
au législateur pour lui permettre de
s'exprimer dans le cadre du mandat qu'il
a reçu du peuple réviser ce règlement
constitue pour le sénat une chance de
consolider sa spécificité
sa légitimité est l'exigence qui est la
sienne dans l'exercice de ses missions
constitutionnelles
c'est dire l'importance de cette
proposition de résolution pour la vie du
sénat son contenu conditionnera pour les
années à venir
nos méthodes de travail au service de la
démocratie et de l'intérêt général
modifier notre règlement nécessité
conformément à notre tradition de
rechercher un accord global des
différents groupes
sur les grandes orientations qu'il
convenait de prendre cela était d'autant
plus nécessaire
ça a été dit mais je le répète qu'aucun
groupe ne détient à lui seul la majorité
absolue au sein de notre assemblée et ça
a été vrai seulement entre 2002 et 2008
à aucun moment depuis 1958 aucun groupe
à lui tout seul n'a des tenues ici la
majorité dans ce domaine il aurait été
déraisonnable de vouloir passer en force
et sans doute d'ailleurs irréalisable la
modernisation est en effet du sénat est
en effet l affaire de tous ainsi la
décision que vous avez prise monsieur le
président de constituer dès le mois
d'octobre
un groupe de travail très large et
pluraliste s'est avérée judicieuse et
déterminante
pendant six mois sous votre autorité
une réflexion approfondie est ouverte a
été menée dans un climat je l' ai
ressenti comme tel
où la confrontation des idées s'est
toujours avéré constructive et
respectueuse des opinions d'autrui et je
veux vous rendre hommage monsieur le
président pour cette initiative qui a
rendu ce travail possible je veux
également félicité les deux rapporteurs
de ce groupe de travail nos collègues
bernard frimat et jean jacques hyest qui
ont su écouter les préoccupations
exprimées par l'ensemble des
participants et les traduire dans les
mesures proposées c'est du moins ce que
j'ai ressenti la démarche poursuivie a
été fructueuse puisque les orientations
de cette proposition de résolution
recueille est me semble-t-il
lors des réunions de ce groupe de
travail la sentiment global des groupes
constituant notre assemblée
r s'articule autour de quatre axes
l'approfondissement du pluralisme
sénatoriales la recherche d'une
organisation plus efficace de notre
travail
la modernisation des procédures de
contrôle en séance publique
et le renforcement de l'action du sénat
en matière européenne
il s'agit comme le soulignait très
justement notre rapporteur patrice
gélard d'un texte qui est à la fois
consensuel équilibrée même si j'ai cru
entendre depuis le début de l'après-midi
des variations sur ce thème que je
n'avais pas pressenti auparavant notre
groupe souscrit aux grandes orientations
de cette réforme est la nouvelle
organisation de l'agenda du sénat va
transformer nos habitudes de travail
avec un temps clairement défini pour les
groupes politiques pour les commissions
et pour la séance publique
chaque sénateur pourra s'investir dans
les travaux de notre assemblée et
conformément à l'esprit général qui a
animé les débats du groupe
la proposition de résolution conforte et
approfondit le pluralisme sénatoriales
je crois qu'il faut reconnaître que les
groupes politiques sont les moteurs
essentiels de la vie parlementaire cette
c2 que tout procède et il était
important de garantir une meilleure
représentation de chacun d'entre eux au
bureau du sénat ou au bureau des
commissions et de leur accorder de
nouveaux droits comme le droit de tirage
pour la création d'une commission
denquête d'une mission commune
d'information et nous n'avons pas
éprouver je crois en tout cas notre
groupe de réticences pour améliorer la
situation
les groupes de l'opposition et les
groupes b minoritaires bénéficient
désormais de droits spécifiques
notamment dans le cadre de la journée
mensuelle réservés ce sont des avancées
majeures et concrètes qui mérite d'être
souligné et constitue je crois un
véritable tournée tournant dans la vème
république
la conférence des présidents va devenir
le lieu d'arbitrage et d'organisation de
la séance
elle sera appelée un euro a joué un rôle
essentiel dans le déroulement de nos
débats et nous nous félicitons que les
groupes politiques en deviennent les
acteurs centraux puisqu'il sera
désormais attribué
président de groupe un nombre de voix
égal au nombre des membres de son groupe
déduction faite évidemment de ceux qui
participent à la conférence des
présidents
nous considérons également comme un
progrès la possibilité pour la
conférence des présidents de décider
d'organiser un débat préalable
d'orientation séance plénière peu de
temps après le dépôt d'un projet de loi
un tel débat cela a été rappelé par le
président georges acquiesce tout à
l'heure le groupe ump du sénat
la plaie de ses voeux il permettra je le
souhaite au porte parole des groupes
d'exprimer leurs positions en amont des
travaux des commissions saisies au fond
les questions cribles enfin favoriseront
la spontanéité de nos échanges avec les
membres du gouvernement dans un esprit
de réactivité par rapport à l'actualité
cette nouvelle catégorie de questions
donnera aux sénateurs la possibilité de
s'exprimer sur un mode plus direct
c'est là je crois une excellente manière
de moderniser notre travail
l'ensemble de ces dispositions donnera
une nouvelle dynamique à notre vie
parlementaire
permettez moi cependant à ce stade de
mon propos de formuler une crainte
un regret est un souhait qui rejoignent
les positions que j'ai avec constance
défendu lors des réunions de notre
groupe de travail même si elles n'ont
pas été pour la plupart d'entre elles
retenu une crainte tout d'abord le
risque de la répétition des débats en
commission puis en séance publique et la
question reste entière
comment absolument
comment mieux articuler les travaux de
la commission et l'examen du texte en
séance publique
est il souhaitable qu'un même amendement
puisse être examiné trois fois lorsque
la commission établit son rapport lorsqu
elle délibère sur les amendements
extérieur
et lorsque le texte est examiné en
séance publique cette situation si elle
n'est pas maîtrisée risque de provoquer
la paralysie de l'ordre du jour
effectivement
l'examen du projet de loi hôpital
patients santé territoire n'a pas même
s'il se déroule dans un climat sérieux
et serein qu'il faut saluer
véritablement apaiser ma crainte il met
en évidence un certain nombre de
difficultés qui s'explique parce que
nous sommes dans une période
d'adaptation mais auquel il nous faudra
apporter des réponses et ces
considérations de bon sens où
semble-t-il m'incite à formuler un
regret que j'ai souvent exprimée lors
des réunions de notre groupe de travail
en effet le groupe ump aurait souhaité
que nous tirions mieux les conclusions
de cette nouvelle donne dans
l'organisation de la séance publique
même si la tradition sénatoriales ne
justifiait pas le recours au temps
législatif programmé
nous pensons que cette question pour des
raisons pratiques devra être revue à la
lumière de l'expérience partagée
l'article 24 de la proposition de
résolution réduit le temps de
présentation des amendements qui sera
désormais de trois minutes mais cela
permettra t'il réellement de raccourcir
nos débats nous avions pour notre part
suggéré que les modalités de prise de
parole sur les articles et les
explications de vote soit réexaminé les
amendements de suppression d'un article
seront désormais systématiquement 10
juin de la discussion commune
c'est un progrès parce que nous sommes
nombreux à reconnaître que les tunnels
d'amendements rendre confus nos débats
et démobilisent les parlementaires cette
question à l'évidence méritera aussi
d'être à nouveau posée l'article 19
a permis de dégager un accord sur
l'organisation de la clôture du débat
ce mécanisme est bon dans son principe
ça fait partie des efforts que j'ai fait
pour qu'on obtienne l'accord global mais
je pense dans la réalité qu'il
s'appliquera en pratique dans peu de cas
conçue oui absolument
conçu ce qui veut dire que pour
rallonger les débats on fera pas mieux
conçus pour sortir de l'enlisement de
nos débats il risque de se retourner
toujours contre son utilisateur qui se
verra on connaît la chanson
instantanément accusés de vouloir
empêcher le débat et bâillonné la
représentation nationale est à cet égard
monsieur le président je pense qu'il
serait utile à un moment ou un autre de
publier les statistiques qui ferait le
point dans le cadre du déroulement d'un
débat sur les prises de paroles et les
pourcentages affecté affecté au
gouvernement la commission aux sénateurs
indivis à titre individuel ou aux
représentants des groupes et ces
chiffres là on se rassure clé de les
connaître parce que vous verrez que ce
ne sont pas ceux que l'on accuse souvent
de vouloir bâillonner la discussion en
séance publique ou de sacrifier les
droits de l'opposition on verra que ce
sont eux qui largement largement
utilisent ce qui leur est possible et
donc par conséquent et je crois que sur
ce plan là véritablement il ne faut pas
nous faire un procès d'intention
il serait véritablement mal venues
d'ailleurs mes chers amis je vous le
donnerai les chiffres sur le projet de
loi santé hôpital santé patients et
territoires et vous verrez je crois et
j'en suis très admirative parce que je
voulais déjà dit que vous êtes en la
matière le champion toutes catégories
mes chers collègues nous sommes tous
pleinement attachés à la séance publique
et au respect du droit d'expression de
chacun mais conduire une nouvelle
réflexion sur des solutions plus
audacieuses
pour le déroulement de nos débats est un
exercice auquel nous serons un jour
contraints de nous livrer pour deux
raisons pratiques
tout d'abord l'ordre du jour est
désormais partagé entre le parlement et
le gouvernement
il nous conduit à devoir examiner en
règle générale en deux semaines ce que
nous faisions auparavant en quatre
semaines et je fais partie de ceux parce
que je les ai entendu évoqué tout à
l'heure qui militait pour que cette
répartition ne soit pas 50 50 mais trois
semaines d'initiative gouvernementale
une semaine d'initiative parlementaire
sénatoriales en l'occurrence et vous
verrez que dans la pratique c'est vers
cette réalité là que nous tend oui on
l'a déjà vu on le voit déjà mais c'est
pas votre détriment c'est au détriment
de notre groupe à nous mais nous faisons
ce sacrifice de bon coeur parce que nous
voulons absolument favoriser la réussite
de la politique gouvernementale
en second lieu la discussion mais je
vous ai dit qu'on le fait de bon coeur
en second lieu oui c'est normal mais en
plus on le fait de bon coeur la
discussion en séance publique porte sur
le texte de la commission
un débat important a donc déjà eu lieu
au sein de la commission et en présence
il décide du gouvernement lorsqu'il
vient en discussion dans l'hémicycle la
volonté du constituant était de
permettre que la séance soit le lieu où
nous nous concentrions en priorité sur
les points les plus sensibles et les
dispositions les plus politiques est en
réalité nous constatons que nous
rentrons de plus en plus avant dans le
détail des mesures est donc je crois
qu'il nous faudra regarder comment on
peut coordonner mieux le moment de la
commission et celui de la séance une
grande partie du travail parlementaire
se jouant ainsi dorénavant en commission
je voudrais me permet de simplement de
rappeler
sous le regard bienveillant du président
larcher parce que nous étions trois à
l'époque il ya 20 ans en 1989 avec notre
collègue guy allouche nous appelions
déjà à l'évolution de l'organisation des
travaux en séance publique
parce que nous souhaitions mais oui nous
souhaitions que le débat en séance
publique soit véritablement le lieu du
débat politique est une des raisons de
la désaffection de la présence dans cet
hémicycle c'est que justement on rentre
beaucoup trop dans le détail et il faut
profiter du fait que le travail en
commissions sort renforcée pour repenser
ce nouvel équilibre sans véritablement
naturellement nuire à la liberté
d'expression de chacune et de chacun
d'entre nous
c'est pour les mêmes raisons qu avec
deux de mes collègues présidents de
groupe
nous nous sommes attachés nous sommes
très attachés à ce que la présence d'un
de nos collaborateurs pendant les
réunions du commission soit 2 devienne
une réalité
le plus rapidement possible en aura
l'occasion d'y revenir
enfin permettez moi de formuler un
souhait cette proposition proposition de
résolution que nous soutenons constitue
à l'évidence une première étape
la modification de notre règlement ne
sera pas à elle seule suffisante pour
parachever la réforme initiée par la
révision constitutionnelle de juillet
dernier notre pratique sera à cet égard
décisive un certain nombre d'évolutions
proviendront de notre propre
comportement comme de celui du
gouvernement
la conviction de notre groupe et qu'il
appartient à chacun d'entre nous de
participer à cette nécessaire
modernisation de nos méthodes de travail
la crainte du changement ne devant pas
l'emporter sur la perspective d'un sénat
plus moderne et plus efficace car c'est
bien l'objectif de votre proposition de
résolution monsieur le président
contribuer par notre règlement à la
modernisation tout entière de notes
institution une phase d'expérimentation
va maintenant s'ouvrir et nous verrons
dans un an maximum
et rien ne nous interdit d'y procéder
auparavant si des ajustements ou des
modifications sont nécessaires
les sénateurs de notre groupe ont fait
je le redis beaucoup d'efforts et
beaucoup de concessions pour rechercher
un accord global et nous regretterions
si comme j'ai cru le percevoir tout à
l'heure
l'ensemble des groupes politiques ne le
manifester pas par leur vote au moment
de la décision et ratifié les
conclusions auxquelles nous sommes
parvenus dans un accord quasi globales
ce serait sympathique que cela puisse se
traduire dans le résultat du scrutin
tout à l'heure à l'évidence le groupe
ump votera votre proposition de
résolution monsieur le président et je
souhaite que l'application de ce nouveau
règlement apporte un nouveau souffle à
l'institution parlementaire dans un
esprit de fidélité à la vème république
à laquelle nous sommes profondément
attachés
si je suis le président c'était l'examen
de la proposition de loi visant à
réformer le règlement du sénat pour
revoir cette séance notre site internet
publicsenat.fr tout de suite le journal
de 18 heures présenté par sonia mabrouk
et michel grossiord merci de votre
fidélité et à très bientôt sur public
sénat